all right
they're life Partners
they're in the same genes so
yeah they told me that before before
they were in the same genes how do we
bring this down so much after this
Syrian guy that was so good yeah it was
killing with the Syria guy am I right
chilling
in your own country
all right do you want to bring them up
do you want to say their names all right
guys please give it up for the very
funny Joe list of Mark Norman yeah
[Applause]
thank you hey everybody
we're in the same shoes we're both
wearing expensive jeans that have no
Ballroom yes it wants skinnier jeans
those are different you're those seem
pretty spacious you have these lines
here you might have painted on those
aren't painting the size you have to
fold them at the bottom because I'm a
shorter man I went to uh Bloomingdale's
this we might not have any this might be
a real bomb here yeah so far it already
is yeah we've got one guy with our left
you look like a butcher
that guy looks like looks like Cleaver I
know but he might use it on you that's
why I'm terrified we have to leave this
way wait a minute you have two pairs of
sunglasses in both pockets
no all right
into breast Pockets glasses of both huh
no wonder you never leave the house
all right I feel like it's all on him
talk to the James uh the jeans well
first of all I went to Bloomingdale's
and it's very weird for him yeah I had a
uh I had a I don't wanna
right a jerk here but I had a TV show to
do so I went to Bloomingdale's I got to
do a TV did you guys notice that
Bloomingdale's episode of cops say
that's what he said all right
sorry if I got a good one you repeat it
all right all right we're gonna butcher
over here yeah
so I went to Bloomingdale's we went to
cleaver
um
[Applause]
you could just say I need clothes and
then a bunch of uh homosexual men run
off and get your clothes Ah that's
pretty good it's amazing they were very
friendly guys you're like a king yeah I
feel like a king and then Cruz yes King
Cruz yeah okay so anyways everyone got
me these clothes they put these pants on
I was like they're too tight I hate them
I can't wear them and they were like
that's what they wear now they wear
tight blue pants but they love if you
didn't mention it you would think these
are as normal everyday pants right madam
yeah as you can see it usually wears a
kimono so
what's a kimono exactly it's something
Asian I think it's like an Asian MooMoo
yeah
I love it was an L yeah I went with it
anyways I liked it yeah what were the
other comedians doing do they have jokes
about that that's a good investment
there we go
good investment
oh geez all right well how about this
please so I uh hooked up with a real
[ __ ] last night
you
were there yeah
this girl she was very young she would
she give me hickeys oh my goodness
I got another date tonight so I had to
cover
yeah but it's not coming up it's
bringing attention to it they got a
Band-Aid well you can't see the hick no
but what are you gonna say when I'll be
the girl okay hello
I cut myself uh doing CrossFit
[Music]
I love CrossFit I do too I am the
captain
[Music]
we just swirl inside of my cut yes
all right oh you really pulled it off
there
nice yeah yes I don't know what to do
who gives hickies and what do we eat 14
yeah hickey we know what the hickey is
she's trying to Mark her territory so
you can't go on the date with the other
girl that's what she's doing I think is
that a good theory is that right ladies
yeah yeah see they want to get you in
trouble they're trying to they're
branding you interesting I don't like it
how about this I have a girlfriend so I
don't get to do this whirly with the c
word but uh I do it with her but you
know less spacious she works out
um a tiny vagina I I got a very insecure
with my looks he's the newly I asked her
today I was like you think I'm a good
looking guy and she said yeah you're the
sweetest
I was like no do you think I'm sexy and
she was like you're always punctual and
I was like what is happening here wow
that works I'm not a good looking guy I
thought I was a good looking guy why
would you think that
[Applause]
I feel good I'm happy I'm a happy guy
I'm tall and a head of hair yeah I'm a
drink of water wouldn't you say talk up
a jizz yeah
yes he's got a solid piece you can't
tell in these uh you can almost tell him
150 bucks the tag is on I'm taking it
back after this show good idea I thought
we're gonna do better but uh he's doing
pretty well all right now it is tough
sledding for a minute I was calling off
the butcher now you're a pretty you're a
pretty good looking guy you get you have
sex
I had a hickey for last night
and they're squared this is how weird
this girl was we're making out in a bar
which is already a little bit of a red
flag we'll call it pink flag which is
also a good name for a gynecologist and
uh I don't know that didn't make sense
all right we're hooking up in the bar
and she's wearing like a tube top number
you know that you get elsewhere and uh I
was making out with her and as a goof I
start to lift the tube top like oh it's
a little hot in here wait for her to be
like what are you doing and she goes
yeah yeah and she pulled it up oh wow
this girl sounds a little topsy-turvy if
you don't want to say yeah she's good
hickey she's got a tube top she picks on
in a barn yeah she's uh she's she's my
kind of gal
[Music]
[Applause]
that's pretty good yeah she was a wild
cat let me ask you this I was on a plane
yesterday flying and you got no internet
on the plane
well this one didn't have an option and
a single engine Cessna
is that a crayon I've heard it sit in a
movie
I was flying from uh from Aruba back to
New York yeah
[Laughter]
baby why don't we go
[Music]
[Applause]
that's all right that got us to cut the
town yeah
very hot airport sticky
[ __ ] Island yes a bit of a hairy
neighborhood
so on the airport
all right so I'm on the airplane and I
had no internet and I have no naked
photos on my phone you probably got a
couple I got a few that's not bad and uh
I'll show you all later so I had none I
got so horny I thought about trying to
draw a legend woman no it was a moment I
was like I'm gonna go draw something
sexy prehistoric porn that's a real low
point trying to figure out so I drew a
couple I'm not a good artist I can't
draw right right oh that's interesting I
never thought of my friend when I was a
kid when he would draw porn interesting
and it was hot he was like a good artist
so it was cool it was very accurate did
he sell it no he showed all the friends
and this is pre-internets we were like
whoa show me that one look at that
c-section scar whatever he knows
detail artists oh yeah he was a dark
dark soul wow do you think people that
made a flip book did you write one of
those books with the uh the bird M's and
W's I love that you guys ever do that it
was on the beach put a sun in there
oh well I had a I was an art student
I don't know some of the squiggly lines
to show heat oh yeah yeah spriggly heat
yeah of course which also works the
smell you put some squiggles here yeah
squiggle could be it could be a fart it
could be a sun it could be movement yeah
I think that's about it yeah
true porn yeah drew some porn but it
didn't really work neither did the bit
so
you guys are a tough crowd we're making
this up at the top of our heads for
God's sakes give us the leeway here we
can't Audrey Joe can't say Cub did it
that's true but it is effective I did I
did draw our [ __ ] but uh all right we
went too far with the c word sorry
everybody what do you do you got a kid
next to you what are you in the middle
seat there was nobody oh I love when
there's nobody it was like an empty it
was like a pre 911 flight it was there's
nobody out there yeah that sounds like
an edgy joke but really before 9 11
there'd be MTC it's on plays a lot
that's true so if you're shaking your
head I don't know what you took wrong
about that it's just a buzzword
3911 was people sitting on a plane with
full liquids well I guess you can still
do that on a plane not dude you can't
bring it on back then you could meet
people at the gate yes they'd come off
and you get my big hug now you got to go
through a rigma roll I don't remember
that I know you made a big poster board
yeah there's no poster board anymore
like a [ __ ] Uber driver
911 they really screwed us they screwed
us yeah and now here's something I don't
want to get to uh PC Richardson thank
you
you make a terrorist joke now people get
weird and then and then they go hey with
Muslims and I'm like well the Unabomber
was a terrorist he's a clean-cut white
[ __ ]
is that right
yes and his name's Ted how scary could
he be right hey Daddy there was a ton of
the show earlier that's right also a
terrorist Alexandra yes
he looks like he's got a beard of a
terror yeah yeah well this is getting
weird
sorry that's a good point just saying
like because your brain went Muslim
don't make me the weirdo right a lot a
lot of non-muslim terrorists yes like in
the 80s movies Bruce Willis I never saw
him fighting a Muslim it was all big
white guys Russians a lot of Russians
Russians let's go with the Russians
because they're away
I don't think people is I know
everyone's cool with Russians
the butcher you look Russian oh
[Music]
[Applause]
it's actually behind me which is odd
sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
yes that's right the only benefit of a
fake people always say when you lay down
they stay up yeah I like when the boob
goes crazy when you lay down like it's
all wacky
from the side and push it back up that's
my favorite part of the moon
[Applause]
I want those groups killing everywhere
yeah because the back is stick straight
up but when it's up by the stick
straight up you want something different
a regular breast is multi-faceted well
let me let me throw this uh wrench in
the anal there
level and a nipple on the on the
mattress or whatever but uh
butt cheek you want the boob moving but
the butt cheek when she's on her stomach
you want that up if there should be more
fake butt cheeks whoa now why is a fake
but okay but not a fake cam no say what
you're saying I'm not saying by the way
I'm not I'm okay with oh it's regular
either but I'm saying do you think I'd
be a higher selling point a fake butt I
like a fake but I I don't think I've
ever felt the fake blood have I I don't
think so either I don't know mine's
really you can see it real well with
these pants on that's right yeah if you
see the tailbone
that's not a tail though
so I'm not perfect either well you can
[ __ ] two girls like this yes
I can [ __ ] tits and ass at the same time
fake or real but I can wear it again
bring it all back home this is got
dirtier than I thought I don't think the
winners should get fake passes I feel
like everyone's judging me now because I
made that joke yeah
yeah
really
there's a lot of fake teeth out there
that's right very acceptable big teeth
you break a tooth you get a new one if
you break a tent you should be able to
get a finger without being judged
it what happened
[Music]
it's I'm not used to having the mics the
mic stand is a universal signal for what
we're wrapping up but I don't have one
so oh you don't have one no I don't get
Alexa so you're trying to use but mine
on both nah that's all right you got it
you let them know that's this well we
got the Easy Bake Oven like going oh
yeah well we should come up with a big
uh big closer big thing a lot of
pressure
there he is will anybody hear a fake
butt cheeks
I just see
no okay no no jeez the course of the day
I can't do it
um for the Middle East Middle East the
Middle East or the Midwest oh both
middle I probably go Middle East really
I've been to both and uh I'm very sad
I was close-minded definitely it's far
easier if I find a uh
a prostitute I was going to say stripper
everybody Welcome to Jeff but you went
prostitute so I think I'm fine now
I went to a brothel in the Middle East
and it was it was very loud oh really
let me throw this uh not get a jizz out
yeah
okay this crowd loves cheers on this
side anyway
Jesus is a real buzzword in the Middle
East porn is illegal yet prostitution is
cool
that's like saying hey you can't uh you
can murder somebody but don't watch Cops
foreign
certainly good I try to draw a high heel
on it
yeah
I don't like them walking around because
I feel bad for the girl like that must
hurt your feet sometimes they get that
weird thing
but I like it is bad I like just a
laying down with a Healer oh I love it
yeah I think as it makes the toes
pointed an orgasm-like way uh it
presents them yes yes
yes I know what's going on with women
you guys aren't really vocal but the
bedroom like
the elect been thrown around do you want
a guy to choke and punch in the tip what
do you want that's what bugs me up with
my girlfriend I can be like put on high
heels and I'm in another world and the
sex happens in two minutes but there's
no [ __ ] I can't just put on a you know a
loafer and she's like yeah let's go
shoot for men I've had this thing in
Cosmo with like they talk about all
these things girls are into like what
turns girls on and it blow my mind
because I didn't know any of them I'm
out there trying to lift weights and new
cables and whatever
but you're funny they're supposed to be
into that yeah but that doesn't you're
funny but then if you're funny in the
bedroom you're like could you stop I'm
getting drunk
that's what I put on a shoe and then
that's done I love it we don't have that
luxury my friend I put a high top and
she squirts everywhere you know
they get paid less we got no sexy shoe
that's true all right we gotta go
everybody
[Applause]